Today, I'm gonna show you a quick and easy way...
...to make these delicious bacon pancakes.
Start by putting 200 grams of self-raising flour into a mixing bowl.
Then add a tablespoon of sugar, a teaspoon of baking powder...
...and a pinch of salt.
Break in an egg.
Then use a whisk to start mixing it all together.
Slowly add 350 milliliters of milk.
And give it a good mix.
When you're done, it should be nice and smooth and look like this.
If you like, you can take an empty sauce bottle...
...and pour in the batter.
You can store it in a fridge for another day.
And just give it a good shake before you come to use it again.
Next, we're gonna warm up some oil in a pan and cook a ration of bacon.
When it's cooked on both sides, take your batter...
...and pour out a pancake around the bacon.
I'm also squirting some over the top.
Cook the pancake on both sides and it's ready to serve.